A GOOD AFTERNOON AS WE COME TO
ORDER WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT.
WE ARE PLEASED THAT ONE BILL
TODAY AB SEVENTY SIXTY ONE WE
WELCOME SEVEN MEMBER SUSHI. AT
TO PRESENT IT BEFORE WE DO LET'S
ESTABLISH RULE PLEASE.
THURMOND HERE FLORA. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. JONES SAWYER PRESIDENT
KALRA.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
WHEN YOU ARE READY TO MOMENTO
THANKS SIR THANK YOU MEMBERS I
AM HERE TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY ONE BAY HOTEL. HOUSEKEEPER
PROTECTION ACT WHICH SEEKS TO
PROTECT HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS AND
OTHER EMPLOYEES.
FROM SEXUAL ASSAULTS AND
HARASSMENT FROM HOTEL GUESTS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MEAT TO MOVEMENT LEADS TO A
SAFER WORKPLACE FOR ALL WOMEN.
INCLUDING HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS.
HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS ARE AMONG THE
MOST VULNERABLE OF WORKING WOMEN
WHO ARE.
ROUTINELY SUBJECTED TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
MANY ARE WORKING CLASS
IMMIGRANTS LATINO AND ASIAN THE
OFTEN WORK ALONE IN HOTEL ROOMS
SOMETIMES OF MALE GAS. PLACE IN
THEM AT RISK OF ASSAULT OR
HARASSMENT.
ACCORDING TO A SURVEY OF C. KAGO
AREAS HOUSEKEEPERS OVER FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE HOUSEKEEPER SAID
THAT THEY HAD BEEN SEXUALLY
HARASSED BY A GUEST IN THE PAST.
AN ALMOST FIFTY PERCENT SAID
THEY HAVE BEEN.
THEY HAD EXPERIENCED AGHAST
ANSWERING THE DOOR NAKED HER
ALTHOUGH OTHERWISE EXPOSING
THEMSELVES AGAIN.
BEING EXPOSED TO THIS TYPE OF
HARASSMENT.
THIS BILL I BELIEVE PROPOSES A
COMMONSENSE PROTECTION FOR THESE
WORKING WOMEN. I AM HONORED TO
HAVE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ALL WANNA MILADA WHO WAS
ONE OF THE COURAGEOUS WOMEN WHO
WAS PROFILED IN THE TIME A
PERSONS OF THE YEAR MAGAZINE. I
AND SHE IS HERE TO SHARE HER
EXPERIENCE.
I THINK A VERY MUCH.
CATHOLIC HE SAME MINE ENEMIES
QUAN NUMBER LARA. AND THE HUSKY
PAIRING THOUGHT THERE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL.
IN A MEMBER OR DENY HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN.
THE PROFITS THEY AMBER I WAS
HONORED TO BE INCLUDED WITH. OR
THEIR KROGER EACH WOMAN US ONE
OF THE ASSIGNMENTS BREAKER.
THAT TIME MAGAZINE NAMED PERSON
OF THE YEAR.
THEY'RE IS SUDDENLY SO THAT
SEVERAL OF OR SEVERAL OF THE
SILENCE BREAKER WHERE.
WHERE PATEL WORKERS
THE HOTEL IN THE THREE CAN BE
DANGEROUS?
PLAY FOR A WOMAN'S TO WORK.
EAST EACH TIME A HOUSEKEEPER
ENTER CALDERON TO CLEAN IT.
CHIEF NOTHING LOW. COULD BEING
FUNNY.
BEING ALONE IN THAT ROOM WE ARE
COMPLETE STRANGER.
MAY ANYONE UNCOMFORTABLE.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE HERE ABOUT THE
HORRIBLE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED.
TO YOUR COWORKERS OR DEFEAT
HOPPING EXPERIENCE ALL OR IF YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCED SOMETHING
YOURSELF.
IT COULD BE GOING TO WORK VERY
SCARY.
THIS ITEM I JUST FEELING.
OVER THE PAST DECADE THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY COMEY SHOWN HOW
THROUGH THIER MOTIVE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINT FLORA HUFF
BATALI HOSPITALITY AND THE
THREE.
THAT ANY OTHER INDUSTRY.
IN CHICAGO OUR UNION SORBET
HOSPITALITY WORKERS TULARE ABOUT
THERE'S.
WITH SOCIAL ROTH MAP OR A FLOW.
ALMOST FIFTY PERCENT OR PUT TEN
WORKERS A MORE THAN SEVENTY
PERCENT HOME WEALTH CASINO
WORKERS SAY. THEY HAVE BEEN
SEXUALLY HARASSED BY GIVE A LEAF
ONCE.
I MYSELF HAVE EXPERIENCED HRS
MEMO WAR FROM THE GAS.
BECAUSE I HAVE SUPPORT FROM MY
COWORKERS IN THE UNION I HAVE
FOUGHT TWO QUARTERS.
THE WITH SPOKE OUT.
BUT TOO MANY WOMAN DO NOT HAVE A
VOICE.
EVERY DAY THEY HAVE TO CLEAN
GROWTH BY DON'T FAIL.
IN WITHOUT ADEQUATE PROTECTION.
TOO MANY EMPLOYERS WILL NOT TAKE
ETHICS THE PROTECT THEM ONLY IF
THEY ARE REQUIRED.
THE THIRD THE QUIET THAT THE
PANIC ABOUT THE LAW IS SO
IMPORTANT.
IN I THINK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
IN MY A PLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAD
AT SOCHI.
FOR IN THROUGH THE WITHIN THE
FBI.
PLEASE THE FAIRWAY HOTEL WORKERS
THEM BOTH YES FOR A. B. THING
SEVENTEEN FIX THE ONE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WITHOUT A FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN BAKER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AYE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I'M ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES OF THE NEW ERA
AND THE POST ME TO ERA IS HOW WE
COME UP WITH POLICY. AYE WITH
POLICIES THAT REALLY PROTECT ON
WOMEN WORKERS IN ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS OF INDUSTRIES THAT REALLY
ADDRESS THE DATA DAY EXPERIENCES
THAT WOMEN HAVE AND THE WOMEN OF
UNITE HERE HAVE REALLY BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THIS MOVEMENT
THEY HAVE BEEN SPEAKING OUT.
THEY HAVE BEEN FIGHTING BACK
THEY HAVE BEEN EMPOWERED THROUGH
THEIR UNION TO BECOME LEADERS TO
TELL THEIR STORIES AND TO CRAFT
THE RIGHT POLICY PRESCRIPTIONS
SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND TO STAND WITH THEM
IN THE FIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WHO WISH TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
A SCENE NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN CALDWELL
THE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL LODGING ASSOCIATION.
FIRST MY SYMPATHY TO THE
WITNESS.
FOR SITUATION BUT WELL NO
INDUSTRY IS IMMUNE TO DEALING
WITH THE AYE ISSUES OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THE HOTEL INDUSTRY IS
COMMITTED TO RAISING THE
AWARENESS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND PROVIDING HOTEL OPERATORS.
WITH THAT THE TRAINING TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TO EDUCATE EMPLOYEES
ON IDENTIFYING AND REPORTING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT.
HOTEL INDUSTRY EMPLOYEES RECEIVE
EXTENSIVE TRAINING TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST HARASSMENT
AND OTHER CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
FURTHER EMPLOYEES ARE TRAINED TO
NOTIFY THEIR SUPERVISORS
MANAGEMENT TEAMS LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN THE INCIDENT OCCURS.
OUR HOTEL BRANDS ARE
IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICES
TECHNOLOGY AND WORKING WITH
SAFETY EXPERTS TO DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES TO
COMBAT THE ISSUE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TO KEEP.
BOTH OUR EMPLOYEES AND OUR
GUESTS SAVE.
IN ADDITION TO THE EXTENT OF
TRAINING OUR EMPLOYEES RECEIVE.
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AGAINST
HARASSMENT OTHER CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY INCLUDING TRAINING TO
NOTIFY THEIR SUPERVISORS
MANAGEMENT TEAMS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHEN ANY INCIDENT
OCCURS THE HOTEL INDUSTRY IS
WORKING SPECIFICALLY TO PROTECT
HOUSEKEEPERS.
FOR EXAMPLE IN LONG BEACH THE
OFFICE DISTRICT.
THE LOCAL TO HOTEL ASSOCIATION
HOLDS QUARTERLY MEETINGS WITH
THE LONG BEACH STE A CHIEF OF
POLICE. AS WELL AS QUARTERLY
REVIEWS OF THE CITY COUNCIL
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
AND ADDITIONALLY THE HOTELS
MAINTAIN A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DOWNTOWN LONG BEACH SECURITY
ALLIANCE.
RECEIVED FEEDBACK FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION SECURITIES DIRECTORS
ALLIANCE AND UTILIZE GLOBAL
HOTEL BRAND IMPROPERLY SPECIFIC
SAFETY AND SECURITY PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING.
SEE SOMETHING SAY SOMETHING
INITIATIVES.
MOST ARE TELLS HAVE HAD TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN THE PAST IN PLACE
FOR MANY YEARS FOR EXAMPLE THE
AMERICAN HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION. HAS A LONGSTANDING
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE TO END SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
AND WORK WITH THEM TO PRODUCE AN
INDUSTRY WIDE TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR HOSPITALITY EMPLOYEES
FOCUSED ON IDENTIFYING SIGNS OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
OFFER ROADWAYS OFFER SUPPORT AND
PRACTICAL WAYS EMPLOYEES CAN
ENSURE SAFER MORE SUPPORT OF
WORKPLACE.
AS TO THE BILL WE ARE PROBLEMS
WITH THE PANIC BUT.
BUTTON PORTION OF THE BILL. BUT
MY COLLEAGUES A FROM THE
CHAMBER.
WILL COVER THAT IN HER
TESTIMONY.
I JUST LIKE TO JUST OF.
BLACK WAS PROVISION.
OF THE BILL. UNDER THIS
PROVISION BILL.
IF ONE EMPLOYEE ASSERTS THAT A
GUEST HARASSED HER.
THAT GUEST IS TO BE BANNED.
FROM EVERY PART OF THE HOTEL FOR
THREE YEARS.
THAT JUST AS NOBILITY TO
CONTEST.
THE THE ALLEGATION.
THERE'S NO DUE PROCESS
BUT UNDER THIS BILL THE HOTEL
WILL BE REQUIRED TO LEARN MOST
OF THE EMPLOYEES AND ALL THE
RESERVATIONS SERVICES THAT THIS
GUEST IS A SEXUAL HARASSER.
THIS A CLEAR VIOLATION OF
PRIVACY.
AND IF IT'S NOT TRUE THE HOTEL
WOULD BE REQUIRED BY LAW TO
SLANDER THE REPUTATION OF A
GUEST.
IN TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT SUCH A
CHARGE IS DEVASTATING.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A
BUSINESSMAN'S ASSISTANT ATTEMPTS
TO MAKE A RESERVATION AT THE
HOTEL IN IS TOLD? HIS BAND
BECAUSE OF HE SEXUALLY HARASSED
MADE.
IF THAT SYSTEM REPORTS THAT
INFORMATION TO OUR SUPERIORS
THAT BANG GUEST WILL GIVEN
TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT PROBABLY
LOSE THEIR JOB.
OR IF HIS WIFE MAKES A
RESERVATION.
I KNOW HOW MY WIFE WOULD RISK.
IT WOULD NOT BE GOOD.
THAT'S THAT'S ONLY PART OF THE
PROBLEM BLACKLIST HOW THE HECK.
IT'S HOTEL SUPPOSED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RIGHT JOHN SMITH IS
BANNED AT THE HOTEL.
THE BILL SAYS THE HOTELS HAVE
DENY SERVICE THOSE THE HOTEL
RESTAURANT SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
LIST OF THE MAJOR DIS AT STATION
AT THE RESTAURANT. AND HUG HOW
THEY KEEP OUT OF WALKING I MEAN
THE PROBLEM IS IF THAT PERSON
WHO'S ON THE BLACKLIST ENDS UP
IN THE HOTEL. THE HOTEL WILL BE
SUIT.
FINALLY. THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT ON PAGE FOUR. THAT
THE BILL DOESN'T DEFINE EITHER
ACT OF VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE CASE OF ACT OF
VIOLENCE TWO SECTIONS OF LABOR
CODER SUGGESTED.
AND IN THE CASE OF SEX
HARASSMENT IS SUGGESTED THAT IT
WOULD BE THAT WHAT WOULD BE
ACTIONABLE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA'S FTA CHECK.
I WE WE AGREE THAT THOUGHT THAT
THAT APPROACH WITH BOTH THE
SUGGESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HIVE ARTIFICIAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WORLD SO HERE IN OPPOSITION.
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THIS BILL AS A
JOB KILLER.
AND I WE AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS OF OF THE HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION AS WELL WE VALUE OUR
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR SAFETY AND
WE WORK TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES
THAT WILL PROTECT THEM IN THE
WORKPLACE. AND THAT MAKES SENSE
BUT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
ARE SIMPLY UNWORKABLE.
MY COLLEAGUE OUTLINED THE MANY
CHALLENGES OF THE BLACKLIST
PROVISION THE ABSENCE OF DUE
PROCESS THE PRIVACY ISSUES AND
THE CHALLENGES HOTELS WOULD FACE
TO IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS.
OUR HOTEL MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED
AND OUR MEMBERS ALSO OUR OUR
HOTEL GUESTS AND THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR DUE
PROCESS AND THEIR PRIVACY.
WE ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS REGARDING THE PANIC
BUTTON REQUIREMENT THAT IT
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ON SCENE
ASSISTANCE. THIS REQUIREMENT IS
TOO BROAD THE BILL DOESN'T
PROVIDE A LIMIT TO WHEN THE
PANIC BUTTON IS USED AND
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ON SCENE
ASSISTANCE TO BE SUMMONED.
IMMEDIATELY ANYTIME IT'S
ACTIVATED
HOW WILL THE LOCATION OF THE
EMPLOYEE BE KNOWN.
UP WITH THIS WOULD REQUIRE GPS
DEVICES FOR ALL FALL IN PLACE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THERE'S NO
INTERNET CONNECTION.
WHAT'S THE ASSISTANCE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE OUR THESE TRAINED.
SECURITY GUARDS SECURITY.
TRAINED RAPID RESPONSE TEAMS
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE HOTEL
WAITING AND READY TO RESPOND TO
AN ACTIVATED PANIC BUTTON.
AND THE ANYTHING LESS COULD
SUBJECT AN EMPLOYER OF CIVIL
PENALTIES EACH DAY THAT THE
RESPONSE TEAMS DEEMED
INADEQUATE.
WE SEE THIS REQUIREMENTS ISN'T
THAT'S OVERLY BROAD AND WOULD BE
VERY EXPENSIVE TO IMPLEMENT. AND
AND THIRDLY THE BILL CREATES A
NEW PAID LEAVE REQUIREMENT FOR
EMPLOYEES TO CONTACT POLICE
PROVIDE A POLICE STATEMENT
CONTACT A COUNSELOR OR AN
ATTORNEY. AND CURRENT LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES
FOR EMPLOYEES TO USE AVAILABLE
TIME OFF FOR THESE PURPOSES AND
WITHOUT RETALIATION. US SO A
PAID LEAVE REQUIREMENT IS
UNNECESSARY SO FOR THESE AND
OTHER REASONS WE ARE POSTED.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION.
NOT IN OPPOSITION WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE I GOT TO THE
COMMITTEE LATE I'M NOT TRYING TO
DESTROY EVERYONE'S EXPECTATIONS
VERY BROAD ON BEHALF OF THE.
UNITE HERE INTERNATIONAL UNION
AND THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T.
IT WAS.
SEAN LOSE THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO POSED THANK
YOU.
MICHELLE RESTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TROUBLE ASSOCIATION
OPENS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FRED MAY.
EXCUSE ME FRED MAIN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALLIANCE VENTURE IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY OPPOSED
MAKE YOU ANYONE ELSE WITH CNN ON
IN OPPOSITION.
AND I'M IN SOME OVER MARROW WITH
UNITE HERE LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE COMING LATE.
SO YOU WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE INTO SUPPORT OF THIS
INCIDENT.
AND THIS IS A BLANCA SHE IS ALSO
FROM THE LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN LP
INTERPRETING FOR THANK YOU.
LONG WAY IF THAT LETS. ME KNOW
WHAT IS BLANCA LA LET ME
DISTILLING. THAT WAS WHICH
EMBODIED THAT CAME TO PUT COOPER
LATEST PAYMENT ON THE POLITICAL.
FOR MY NAME IS BLANCA.
AND I CAME HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE INITIATIVE I'M FROM OPEN.
KIT IN THE SEA OF THE COCONUT
APPLAUSE ALMOST LOST MUSCLE OF
MANY BROKERS FROM THE SCENE.
BUT LOOK AT THE QUICKIE
SO MOST OF.
LEVEES THIS IMPORTANT MUSCLE
THIS KICK IT CAN REALLY MESS
WITH WESLEY LIST BENEATH HIM.
SO RIGHT NOW FROM WHAT I'M
HEARING.
IT FEELS TO ME THAT. YOU KNOW
IT'S HOTEL WORKER MYSELF I FEEL
LIKE I'M SOMEONE WHO IS NOT TO
BE CONSIDERED OF BECAUSE I'M
HEARING MORE WILLING WHICH OF
US.
YOU KNOW BE MORE CONSIDERATE OF
A GUEST OVER THE WORK OVER THE
EMPLOYEES IN THE WORKERS.
GIL IS ST THE LOCAL BASE THEATER
DOES THE US IN THE LETTER THAT
WAS SENT WITH.
EMAIL BUT IF IT ALL IN MINNESOTA
LOW HEELED THE STORY.
A PART OF A VEHICLE MODELS
DEFICITS IS A BE SENT INTO
GLORIOUS PUYEHUE CARLOS GONNA
GIVE EFFECT UMBILICAL BAILIFFS.
SO I I WORK OF ITS WITHIN THE
ROOM SERVICE FOR TWO DAYS AT THE
HILTON GARDEN IN AND OUT IN THE
OPEN.
GOMEZ POSTED LOOK IN THE SILICON
THIS MOSQUITOES BITING PERSON
WHO WILL HAVE MOST
IT CAN AND WILL HAVE MOST OF THE
SECOND AND WHAT PROPONENTS
BRIXTON IN MY LEGS.
ESO NOT THE MENTAL THROUGH SOME
OF MY PASSION BICU.
THE FAMILIAR BUT I QUE LOS THEY
MUST KNOW A PUBLIC BUT IT COULD.
BUT IT LOOKED AT ONCE AND WITH
SO MUCH I JUST AS CONVINCED AS
SOME SORT OF FEEL.
NONE THE LESS ON SEVERAL
SETTLEMENT CHAIRMAN IS THE
COMMAND IS OPENNESS ON THE PHONE
NOT COMMODITIES.
AND MY EXPERIENCE IN ROOM
SERVICE I'VE DONE CAME INTO
ROOMS WHERE DOES HAVE BEEN OPEN
WITH GUEST ARE YOU THERE IN
BATHROBES MAKE A.
BEING YELLED THAT PROCESS
BRINGING IN THEIR FOOD. AND TO
ME THAT'S SOMETHING IT MAKES ME
FEEL AS A PERSON S. IF I'M
IMPORTANCE.
AND.
AND IN TERMS OF THE PANIC BUT
INSIDE I IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
HEAR ANYTHING THAT IS NOT
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THESE KIND OF
BUNNINGS WHEN. I'M GOING INTO
ROOMS FOR ROOM SERVICES AT
ELEVEN TWELVE AT NIGHT.
BY MYSELF.
PHYLLIS BUT THE CELESTIAL
POLITICAL ME THAT LIST COULD BE
DOUBLE WHAT THOSE AT RISK
ASSESSMENTS AND PROTOCOL MINDS
WILL MEAN THEY. HIT THE SYSTEM
OF THE MOVEMENT.
CONCORD MILITANT THE MOST LESS
WHICH ADVOCACY OF BY FEW BUT.
JUST AN INCH OF HEARING
COMMENTARY TODAY RIGHT NOW HOW
YOU KNOW JUST BECAUSE WE'RE
SOMEWHERE THE FOLKS WHO BRING IN
THE FOOD THAT WORK THERE. AND
I AM BUDGET HEARINGS COMMENTS I
FEEL LIKE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING WHERE LIKE I
FEEL LIKE I'M I'M NOTHING IN
THIS TIME WITH A STORE IN THIS
BUSINESS.
LET'S LISTEN LEARN US PREMIES
WERE DONE ON MARKET CAPITALISM
MUSCLE POLICE.
AND JOSE ABUSE AND NOT ONLY
THAT.
IN IN IN A STYLE I HOST AND
EARLY THAT'S LESS COMBINED YOU
KNOW THAT BUT I THINK THE LITTLE
THE LITTLEST PERSONAS.
IN A POLYMER RECEIVING UP GET
KIMBERLY THAT ON THE MONEY
CERTAINLY CONTAIN.
AND UNLESS IF YOU TO TALK FOR
MYSELF A MERE THOUGHT.
IN BEHALF OF MY COWORKERS.
ROOM SURVEYS AND HOUSE KEEPING
AND IN THE END OF THE DAY EVEN
WHEN WE DO STAND UP AND SPEAK
OUT IN DEFENSE JUSTICE IS. THEY
DON'T BELIEVE US IN THE OTHER
DAY.
LOOK EVEN AT THE LEVEL CO SIGN
ON OF THE NATO IN THE SURPLUS.
BUT CERTAINLY VULCAN WAS
SYMPATHETIC BUT A CONSTANT
ASSIST AYE YOU THEY MOST
ESCUTCHEON.
YOU KNOW SUB WILLIAM ADVANCED.
IF IF THE ACADIAN THE BUS THAT.
GET A CEASE.
AND ALTHOUGH THE FOLKS ON TOP OF
THESE INDUSTRIES DON'T WANNA
LISTEN TO WAS LARA HERE THAT OUR
CONCERNS I HOPE THE TODAY YET
WITH MY TESTIMONY DOUBLE YAKKING
HERE WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM.
AND BE IN SUPPORT OF THIS NEW
LAW THANK YOU.
INVESTORS.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON
IN OPPOSITION AND.
WE DID.
HAVE SOME LATE SUPPORT.
EXTENDED THAT WE WOULD EXTEND
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO THE
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL.
SEEING NONE OF THAT WILL TAKE IT
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SEEN RIMMER STYGIA.
AND OPEN IN PARTICULAR THE TO
WORKERS I SPOKE COULD BE CERTAIN
THAT. YOU ARE NOBODY'S YOU'RE
SOMEBODY YEARS CERTAINLY BEING
HEARD BY US AND SO WE DUFFY
APPRECIATE YOU.
SPEAKING OF ABOUT WHAT MATTERS
TO YOU.
AND AND THAT'S OUR JOB IS TO
HEAR TO HEAR THAT OF TO COOLEY
THE MEMBERS A COUPLE MENTIONS
THE ME TOO MOVE MEN AND. IN A
LOT OF THE EARLY FOCUS BEING ON
FOOT HOLLYWOOD IN THE HALLS OF
THE CAPITOL BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT IT'S IT'S COURAGEOUS AND
IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE.
AT YOU WITH THE JANITORS THE
HOME CARE AIDES AND THE HOTEL
WORKERS THAT ARE PREDOMINATELY
WOMEN WORKING. IN A WORKING
ALONE IN CLOSE QUARTERS OF THESE
ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT I
THINK THAT WE WOULD BE REMISS OF
OUR DUTY IF WE WEREN'T. TAKING
UNDEAD DEEP CONSIDERATIONS I
THANK THANK YOU ARE MISSING
MURATSUCHI FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. AYE A COUPLE
THINGS ONE IS I I DON'T.
HAVE ISSUES WITH MOST
POLITICALLY THE PAID TIME OFF I
MEAN. AS SOMEONE TO SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AYE AND AND AN
EMPLOYER DOESN'T. WANT TO TAKE
VACATION OR SICK TIME TO RESOLVE
THE I THINK WE HAVE LOST A
LITTLE MORE COMPASSION THAN
THAT.
AND THE SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW
THESE BUTTONS GONNA BE PUSHED
LIKE IT'S SOME KIND OF GAME
THAT.
LETS GIVE THE WOMEN MORE CREDIT
THAN THAT.
THAT THAT JOB ARE JUST MY
PROTECT THEMSELVES TO DURING
HOURS OF EMPLOYMENT. I JUST TRY
TO DO THEIR JOB. BUT ALSO THE
PANIC BUT I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE PANIC
BUTTON ISSUE BECAUSE LIKE I GET
A THERE'S COST INVOLVED WHAT
HAVE YOU ALTHOUGH THEY'RE MORE
READILY AVAILABLE NOW.
I THINK THEY'VE EVER BEEN AND
CHEAPER THAN EVER AYE YOU TO
THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY FOR
CONVERSATION WITH OTHER THE
AUTHOR THE SPONSORS BECAUSE
OPPOSITION ON. I'M GONNA THEY'RE
THERE NOW SOUTH ON APPS THERE
ARE THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES I
THINK.
AND AND MOST FOLKS INCLUDING
THE HOTEL WORKERS MANY OF WHOM
MCCARTY HAVE SMARTPHONES AT THE
MAYBE AN OPPORTUNITY USE APPS
AND AND DO SOME CREATIVE THINGS
OF THAT COST IS A REAL CONCERN I
I THINK THAT. I DON'T THINK
ANYONE TRY DRIVE UP BECAUSE THIS
REALLY BUT THAT'S WHAT'S THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAY OF MAKING
SURE THAT IF SOMEONE IS IN
DANGER THAT THEIR HELPED. AND I
CAN'T IMAGINE I DON'T KNOW OF
AND CAN'T IMAGINE ANY. HOTEL
MANAGEMENT OR OWNER THAT IF
THEIR WORK WAS IN TROUBLE THEY
WOULD WANT TO BE THERE IN AN
INSTANT.
AND AND IF THAT'S NOT THE CASE
YOU WOULDN'T WANT TO WORK FOR
SOMEONE LIKE THAT THAT WOULDN'T
WANT TO BE THERE WHEN SOMEONE IS
IS LEGITIMATELY. IN TROUBLE AND
SO I THINK THAT THAT THAT CAN BE
FIGURED OUT.
A AND SO I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THAT CONTENTION I JUST HAD WITH
THE ONE IT AREAS THE BLACKLIST
AREA. AND ON AMONG JUDICIARY AS
WELL AS THERE'S NOT A LOT I'M
CERTAINLY GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS
TODAY.
BUT THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE CONVERSATION ON THE
BLACKLIST I THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME DUE PROCESS ISSUES AND I
THINK THERE'S MORE BY.
DETAILS THAT I'D CERTAINLY LIKE
TO SEE AYE AS TO HOW IT WOULD.
THE BY HOW IT ACTUALLY OPERATE
AND PRACTICAL PURPOSES AYE AS
OPPOSED TO THE THEORY OF IT IN
THEORY OF COURSE IF THERE'S
SOMEONE THAT IS OF A PREDATOR.
HELP WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
CONTINUE TO PREY ON PEOPLE BUT
BRING IT DOWN TO A REAL LIFE THE
REALITY AND THE APPLICATION OF
IT BOTH GIVEN DUE PROCESS AS
WELL AS. PRAGMATIC APPLICATION
OF IT BUT IN JUDICIARY I I
CERTAINLY WILL LOOK. LOOK TO
YOUR MORE SPECIFICITY AND AND
MORE CONVERSATIONAL PLEA OF WHAT
THE AUTHORS OFFICE OPPOSITION AS
WELL AS A SPONSORED A AND AND
AND MOST DIFFICULT HE THE AB THE
JUDICIARY STAFF WRITING THAT
ISSUE IS MORE APPROPRIATELY.
PLACED SO I'M BUT THANK YOU FOR
BEING THE BILL FORTY PERCENT.
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS SOME
REMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
FOLLOWED BY SOME REMEMBER JONES
SAWYER SOMEONE ECHO EVERYTHING
THAT MY COLLEAGUES SAID THIS IS
A GREAT BILL AND. I KNOW IT'S
PART OF MOVEMENT I ACTUALLY
WANTED TO AUTHORED THE BILL AND
YOU GOT IT FIRST YEAH.
THANK YOU I WOULD SAY AT FIRST
OF ALL I THOUGHT WAS GOING TO MY
COMMITTEE APPARENTLY IT'S NOT SO
I'D LOVE TO BE CO AUTHOR.
IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. I.
I WAS CONCERNED WITH IN THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS ARE JUST
SOME QUESTIONS I MEAN I REALIZE
EVEN THOUGH I SPENT.
COUNTLESS STAYS AT A HOTEL I
LIVE IT A HOTEL I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT PROTECTIONS THERE ARE NOW A
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT THERE ANY AS
A GUEST OF A HOTEL ALMOST
NIGHTLY? I'VE NEVER BEEN TOLD
HOW I CAN OPEN THE DOOR OR HOW I
SHOULD BE DRASTIC OR SHOULD I BE
TRUSTED BY ORDER ROOM SERVICE.
WHAT WHAT HOTEL STUDENT AT WHAT
ARE THE RULES NOW?
THERE ARE NO RULES CRACKED.
HOTELS DON'T TELL GAS I'M NOT
SURE I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE THE PROTECTIONS
FOR A ROOM SERVICE.
OF A WORKER OR A HOTEL WORKER.
GUESTS ARE NEVER. TO MY
KNOWLEDGE IN MAY BE AMONG THE
BAY SIGN SOMETHING IN SMALL
PRINT OUR GUESTS TOLD IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE TO IT TO. HAVE A
WORKER COME INTO YOUR ROOM IF
YOU'RE NAKED.
OKAY IN THAT SEEMS SO LET'S
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT THAT SEEMS
PRETTY BASIC RIGHT. IT SEEMS
LIKE MOST OF US WOULD UNDERSTAND
YOU PROBABLY SHOULDN'T DO THAT.
SO IT WOULD SEEM THAT IF FOR NOT
TELLING PEOPLE WE KNOW YET IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE AT THAT THE
SURVEYS HAVE BEEN DONE WE KNOW
THAT HAPPENS OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. IN MY FORMER LIFE
WORK WITH A LOT OF. UNITE HERE
LOCAL THIRTY MEMBERS IN AND
HEARD THESE STORIES SOME.
SCARY SOME FUNNY.
.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENS AND YET
THAT VERY BASIC THING OF LIKE.
EXPECTED CONDUCT OF AGHAST IS
NEVER TOLD TO A GAS NOW CRACKED
THE YOU'RE AWARE OF.
THERE MIGHT BE A HOTEL OUT THERE
THAT DOESN'T BUT.
I'M NOT NOT GOING TO.
SO IN YOU'RE.
DESCRIPTION OF ALL THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE GOING ON AND WHAT
IF THAT VERY SIMPLE THING ISN'T
HAPPENING WHAT WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO PROTECT.
THESE PRIMARILY WOMEN.
WELL THAT AS A SUDDEN STATEMENT
AND.
THERE ARE.
THERE'S TRAINING PROGRAMS TO TO
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW TO TO WHAT TO
WATCH FOR I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN IT COMES TO TO MATE YOU'LL
SEE YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE. AND A LOT
OF A LOT OF THE HOTELS WE PUT
TO.
TWO TOGETHER.
SO THAT YOU DON'T KNOW NOBODY'S
BOTTOMS YOU KNOW BY THEMSELVES
AND THE LARGER HOTELS OR. WHAT
IS THE STATE WHAT HOTEL STILL
USES THAT STANDARD I'M CURIOUS?
I I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT STANDARD.
LAST LAST FEW WHEN I WAS I WAS
IN THAT'S UPDATED.
OKAY WELL.
I MEAN I'VE ONLY I'VE ONLY SEEN
THE STANDARD OF UNIONIZED MAIDS
WHICH HAVE A HIGHER STANDARD
THAN NON UNION AND I HAVEN'T
SEEN.
DUAL WORKERS IN AWHILE I COULD
BE WRONG I'M NOT AN EXPERT IN
THE INDUSTRY ADJUSTS.
ALRIGHT THAT THE MAIDS ARE
SAYING THAT'S NOT REALLY A
STANDARD IN THE BUSINESS SO.
BESIDES BESIDES MAYBE THE HOTEL
THAT USES TO. WORKERS AND.
WHAT I HEARD FROM YOU IS YOUR
TRAINING THE WORKERS BUT?
THE WORKER CANNOT DETERMINE THE
WORKER CAN'T BE TRAINED AGAINST
BEING VIOLATED.
FROM FROM A PATRON OPENING THE
DOOR.
RIGHT HOW HOW CAN YOU TRAIN A
WORKER.
TO STOP A GUEST FROM.
VIOLATING THEM.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE DON'T
GOVERNMENT WHAT YOU CAN AND WHAT
WE CAN DO IS IS TO. TO TO CREATE
A BUT PROCESS OF BACON REPORTED.
OKAY WHAT HAPPENS WHEN OUR A
WRECK RIGHT NOW WHEN WHEN.
A LET'S SAY IT'S MADE.
THE CLEAN ROOM TO A SEVEN.
THREE DAYS IN ROW THEY'VE
COMPLAINED EVERYDAY THE PATRON
OF IT TO A SEVEN OPENS UP.
AND HE'S NAKED OR SHE'S MAKE IT.
WHAT HAPPENS?
THERE'S NO RULE FOR THE GASTRITE
SIDE ASSUME THE HOTEL CAN'T
REALLY TELL THE GAS THAT THEY'VE
DONE SOMETHING WRONG WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS.
DEPENDS ON WHAT EACH HOTEL HOW
THEY WOULD.
SO I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY AND I
I COULD BE WRONG AGAIN I'M NOT
AN EXPERT I LIVE IN A HOTEL THE
NON EXPERT AND SKILLED AT ALL. I
JUST WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT
PROBABLY NOTHING HAPPENS.
RIGHT I MEAN I'VE NEVER HEARD OF
SOMETHING HAPPENING.
BESIDES IF.
I'M JUST WONDERING BECAUSE I.
DO WE HAVE.
IS THERE A STANDARD IN THE
INDUSTRY THIS IS AN ONGOING
SERIOUS ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING FOR YEARS AND IT JUST
SEEMS THAT THERE'S NO REAL
STANDARD. I'M FOR PROTECTING.
THESE WOMEN IF YOU WOULD SIR IF
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF ARE YOU
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS QUESTIONS NOTHING WE
WELCOME YOUR. LYNN MORE FELT
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION SO THERE ARE CODE OF
CONDUCT.
AND MANY HOTELS HAVE THEM BUT
ITS OWN INDIVIDUAL BASIS OR.
I GET THE BRAND BASIS SO SOME
HOTELS WILL HAVE WON SOME DOWN
TO.
AND IT DEPENDS ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL BRAND IN TERMS OF
YOUR EXAMPLE OF A HOTEL GUEST
EXPOSING THEMSELVES I'M IF
THAT'S REPORTED.
THAT HOTEL GUEST IS GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED AND IF THAT'S NOT
RESOLVED AT THAT POINT.
THAT HOTEL GUESTS WILL BE ASKED
TO LEAVE WE WILL REFUSE THEM
SERVICE SO HAVING THAT HAPPENED
THREE TIMES IN A ROW THAT'S NOT
A REALITY.
IN IN THE INDUSTRY AT ALL NOT
NOT FOR THE SAME GAS THERE'S NO
WAY. VERY BUT IF I.
HAD SOMEBODY EXPOSE ME ON THE
STREET THAT THE POLICE WOULD BE
CALLED.
OKAY SHOW BUY I THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A SNEAK I'M I'M JUST KIND
OF UNDER I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND SO. IT'S A AWKWARD
SITUATION BY IT FILE MEANS LIKE
I SAID I LIVE IN A HOTEL SO I
UNDERSTAND HOW AWKWARD IS FOR
ESPECIALLY BUSINESS TRAVELERS
TO.
YOU KNOW THE SUMS LIKE YOUR
PLACE OF LIVING AND. SO. I AGREE
THERE CAN BIG THERE CAN BE
GASSED
IN TERMS OF GUEST EDUCATION I'M
AND WHAT THEY DO BUT I'M GONNA
SAY THAT THE NORMAL PERSON AND
THE AVERAGE VISITOR. KNOWS THAT
THEY SHOULDN'T ANSWER THEIR DOOR
NAKED.
AND I THINK THAT'S JUST A
STANDARD OF SOCIETY SO I THINK
THAT WE'RE DEALING AYE I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S A STANDARD
OF SOCIETY NOT TO. TOOK ABOUT
YOURSELF ANYBODY BUT IT HAPPENS
AND AND I THINK THAT MOST OF OUR
WHERE I WAS GOING WITH THIS IS.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
HOTEL SIDE WERE INTERESTED
PROTECTING THE WORKERS AND
INTERESTED IN PROTECTING THEM SO
JOHN MENTIONED TO DO AROUND.
IT'S MORE TO DO A FLOOR OR
PUTTING THEM ON THE FLOOR.
MEAN AND WITH A SUPERVISOR AS
WELL OR ANOTHER HOUSE MINUTES
WELL SO THERE'S SAFETY IN
NUMBERS SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
HOTELS THAT HAVE VOLUNTARILY PUT
IN PANIC BUTTONS.
AND THEY HAVE THOSE AND THEN
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF OPERATIONAL
ISSUES IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
POSITION THE CARTS.
.
HOUSEKEEPERS GENERALLY DON'T GO
INTO A ROOM WHERE THERE IS
SOMEONE THERE TO CLEAN THE ROOM.
THAT IS NOT STANDARD PROTOCOL NO
ONE IS USUALLY IN A HOTEL ROOM
WHEN THE GUEST IS IN THAT ROOM.
THE ONLY TIME THAT I'VE EVER
SEEN THAT IS FOR TURNDOWN
SERVICE WHERE IT'S REAL QUICK
HEY DO YOU WANT SOME WATER SO I
MEAN HE'S TURNED OUT. YES I
WILL.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO HOTEL WORKERS
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I HAD A LOT
OF.
.
IT.
OKAY MAYBE WE'VE JUST HAD
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES OF COURSE
MY EXPERIENCE IS ONLY. AS HOTEL
GUESTS AND THEN SEPARATELY AS A.
WORKER ADVOCATE THAT I DID
BEFORE I CAME HERE AND HEARD A
LOT OF STORIES FROM WORKERS
HOTEL WORKERS ABOUT THINGS THAT
INDIVIDUAL GAS CAN DO LIKE.
COME ON AND I DON'T I JUST
WANTED TO TAKE HER MY TRASH AND.
YOU KNOW MY TOWELS AND YOU KNOW
THAT IS IT IT. COMMON STANDARD
PROCEDURE IS FOR THE HOUSEKEEPER
ONLY TO BE IN THE ROOM WHEN
THERE'S NO CAST IN THE BROWN.
SO HOUSE KEEPER SHOULD NOT ENTER
THAT ROOM WHEN A GAS IS IN THE
ROOM UNLESS THE GUESTS IF
THEY'RE COMFORTABLE WITH IT AND
I GUESS REQUESTED.
INFILL THERE TWENTY ROOMS TO BE
CLEANED WITHIN THEIR SHIFT.
AYE OKAY.
I MEAN TAKE YOUR WORD FOR IT
THAT WE SHOULD ALL JUST ABIDE BY
COMMON DECENCY AND THAT THERE
ARE SOME STANDARD POSSIBLY THAT
EXISTS WITH SOME HOTELS. AND
THAT SOMETIMES MAYBE MAYBE OUR
HOUSEKEEPERS SOME.
SOME. VERY GOOD EMPLOYERS GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY NOT GO INTO
A ROOM AND YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY
DON'T GET THEIR ROOMS CLEAN THAT
THEY NEED TO GET. CLEAN DURING
THEIR SHIFT BECAUSE I KNOW.
HOTEL OWNERS AREN'T STRICT ABOUT
THAT AT ALL.
BUT LET'S SAY IT EXISTS OUT
THERE.
DON'T YOU SEE WHERE THERE'S NO
STANDARD THAT'S PROTECTING THESE
MAINLY FEMALE WORKERS THERE'S NO
I'D LIKE EVEN THAT'S WHERE.
WE'RE DISAGREEING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS MAJORITY OF THE TIME
JUST FROM TALKING TO DIFFERENT
WORKERS.
I I GUESS I LOOK AT IT FROM WE
HAVE A FRAMEWORK
FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT SHOULD
SIXTY TWO WE HAVE A FRAMEWORK
FOR THIS AND WE ALREADY HAVE
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES. ARE
MANAGERS ALL TAKE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING WERE OUT
THERE AT THIS IS WHERE AN INNER
EDUCATING AS MUCH AS WE CAN ON
THIS TO BRING THIS UP TO THE
ISSUE.
OUR HOUSEKEEPERS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND VALUABLE TO US.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE A SAFE WORKING
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL SO WE WANT
TO DO THE RIGHT THING HERE AND
WE WANT O EDUCATE. SO FAR
EDUCATION HAS FOCUSED PRIMARILY
ON KEEPING THE WORKERS OUT OF
HARM'S WAY.
HOW DID YOU IT WHAT TO DO IT
WHAT THE SAFETY PRECAUTIONS ARE
WITH THE PROTOCOLS ARE?
EVERY MAJOR BRAND
HAS SAFETY AND AND SECURITY
PROCEDURES IN THE HOTEL. JUST
BEYOND THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
EVERYTHING ELSE WE'VE GOT OTHER
SAFETY ISSUES AS WELL IT'S
OBVIOUSLY A A BIG ISSUE IN OUR
INDUSTRY SHOWING WE ARE ALWAYS
EVOLVING IN TERMS OF WHAT THOSE
STANDARDS ARE. AND WHAT THOSE
PROTOCOLS ARE
SO HAVE YOU SEEN SOME OF THE
SURVEYS DONE BY UNITE HERE ABOUT
WHAT.
THEIR WORKERS EXPERIENCE ON THE
JOB AS FAR AS I KNOW THERE IS
ONE SURVEY THAT SADDAM WAS DONE
IN CHICAGO.
IN THAT SURVEY.
TOOK OUT.
LOOKED AT.
WHAT THE DATA WAS AND IT SAID
OVER THE COURSE OF THEM BEING
EMPLOYED FOR THEIR THEIR
INDUSTRY?
THEIR CAREER AS A HOUSEKEEPER.
HAD THEY THE QUESTION WAS SUCH
THAT IT WASN'T IN THE PAST YEAR
TWO WASN'T IN THE PAST TEN YEARS
IT WAS OVER THE COURSE OF THEIR
OF THEIR. CAREER AND SO THOSE
ARE THE NUMBERS THAT I NOW.
I'M SURE THAT THAT'S THE ONLY
THAT'S THE ONLY STUDY THAT I'M
AWARE OF THE INDUSTRIES THAT
EVER DONE A STUDY ON BEHALF OF
THE WORKERS THEY CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT. I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT I HAVE NEVER DONE A
STUDY ON IT I'M SURE THAT THERE
ARE. HOTEL SAFETY STANDARD AND
STUDIES OUT THERE SO OKAY YES I
WOULD SAY THEIR STUDIES I'M
UNAWARE I'M JUST GONNA SUGGEST.
THAT.
IN PARTICULAR.
THE HOTEL INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
VERY DISMISSIVE AND I THOUGHT
THE COMMENTS TO BE HONEST WERE
VERY DISMISSIVE TODAY AND I WAS
SOMEWHAT OFFENDED BY SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE. OUTRIGHT WITH
SOME BEING I'M VERY.
IT AND PERHAPS IT WAS IT.
NOT.
ON PURPOSE BUT LIKE EVEN TO SAY
WHAT IS A MAN TO DO WHEN HIS
WIFE MAKES A HOTEL RESERVATION
FOR HIM THAT JUST WE SHOULD
THINK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
WE'RE PRESENTING THESE.
SITUATIONS OKAY.
.
AT.
NOW.
I'M ALMOST DONE HERE I'M
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
I'M.
I THINK IF THE INDUSTRY WERE
SERIOUS.
THAT.
THEY WOULD TAKE A LOOK AFTER ALL
THE STORIES ARE OUT THERE AFTER
LOOK THE MOST FAMOUS WHAT WAS
THAT THE IMF HAD TO YOU KNOW
RATE OF MADE RIGHT WE KNOW THESE
THINGS HAVE EXISTED FOR AWHILE.
IN BECAUSE I'M NOT I'M NOT
CERTAIN.
THAT EVEN OUR MOST RESPONSIBLE
ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY THE
UNIONIZED ACTORS ARE DOING
ENOUGH WE KNOW THAT THOSE WHO
DON'T HAVE.
WORKER PROTECTIONS PUT IN PLACE
OR DEMANDED BY THE UNION REALLY
AREN'T DOING ANYTHING OR IT
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S ANYTHING
BEING DONE TO PROTECT BOTTOM
HOUSEKEEPERS IN PARTICULAR. AND
I THINK IT'S SHOCKING THAT GIVEN
HOW LONG THIS HAS BEEN IN THE
NEWS THAT NOTHING.
I'M NOT SIGNING ANY KIND OF
COMFORT AND WHAT'S BEEN OFFERED
SO I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BLACKLIST NOT THAT CONCERNED I'M
TO BE HONEST BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
REPORTING OF PEOPLE I'M.
AND INTENTIONALLY OR WRONGLY
THAT DIDN'T DO SOMETHING WRONG
BUT I GET WE HAVE TO WORK ON THE
DUE PROCESS ASPECT IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WHICH HOPEFULLY I'LL
BE SITTING ON.
BUT I WOULD TELL THE INDUSTRY
THAT IF YOU'RE SERIOUS ABOUT NOT
FACING A BILL LIKE THIS WHETHER
THAT'S GETS THROUGH THIS YEAR OR
CITY BY CITY OR AREA BY AREA YOU
MAY WANT TO NUMBER ONE. DO A
SURVEY OF YOUR OWN WORKERS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SAFE MOST OF YOUR WORKFORCE ARE
A LARGE PART OF YOUR WATCHER
FORCE ARE IMMIGRANT WORKERS WHO
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS MAY NOT
FEEL AS COMFORTABLE COMING
FORWARD IN THOSE SITUATIONS. AND
I THINK YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE GETTING EXACTLY. WHAT
WHAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING HERE IN
THIS BILL AND I THINK THAT THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN IF  WE WERE
IN A DIFFERENT INDUSTRY SHOULD
BE THOSE WORKER SAFETY IN SUCH A
BE HERE AS WELL I'M? I'M HAPPY
TO MOVE THE STUFF.
REMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
HOME.
BUT AS SOMEONE.
.
WHO HAPPENED TO TO MANAGE?
?
A LARGE GROUP OF.
.
PEOPLE IN CUSTODIAL.
AND.
AND BEING WITH A GROUP OF
MANAGERS OVERSEEING THAT GROUP
AND ONE DAY THE FI.
THAT ONE OF OUR MANAGERS WAS
MOLESTING MOST ELECTING OUR. AND
AFTER AMERICAN WOMEN. AT ON THE
NIGHT SHIFT.
AND GET A GOVERNMENT BUILDING.
.
NOT ONLY WAS IT EMBARRASSING
AND.
.
EXTREMELY HURTFUL AND THE
STORIES WE HEARD.
UNBELIEVABLY PAINFUL
I MEAN.
AND WE HAD RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
ON BUT THINGS FELL THROUGH
CRACKS AND.
AND WE REALLY FELT BAD BECAUSE
WE CAN DO ENOUGH.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING.
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
OF THAT.
WE NEED TO TAKE THIS.
TO THE NEXT LEVEL TO MAKE THIS A
WIN WIN FOR EVERYONE. ON.
IF I COULD TELL YOU EVEN JUST.
ONE TEMPTED THE STORIES THAT I
HEARD.
DISCOVER STATION WOULD CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY.
.
THAT INDIVIDUAL NOT ONLY WAS
FIRED BUT WE WE TURNED THEM
OVER.
TELLY PT.
AND.
.
AND I I JUST HOPE.
HE GETS ALL THAT HE DESERVED
BECAUSE WHAT WAS GOING ON.
IT UNDER UNDER MANAGEMENT.
EYES LUIS WAS UP REALLY
HORRENDOUS.
AND AND.
AND SO I AS WE MOVE.
FORWARD AND.
MISTER MURATSUCHI
I BELIEVE YOU'RE EVEN I'D LOOK
AT SOME THINGS IN AND MAKE SURE
WE CAN TIGHTEN UP.
SOME THIS LANGUAGE I'M AND
HOPEFULLY BEGINNING WITH THAT
THE PANIC BUTTON.
.
I I DON'T SEE THAT BEING A
PROBLEM MAYBE OTHER THAN
EXPENSE.
.
I WAS WITH MY GRAND CHILD OVER
THE WEEKEND AND.
HIS NINETY YEAR OLD GREAT
GRANDMOTHER'S WATCHING HIM AND I
TOLD MY DAUGHTER YOU PROBABLY
NEED SOME KIND OF ALERT BUTTON.
IT'S GRANDMA'S OVER NINETY SHE
MAY FALL AND WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY RIGHT NOW NOT ONLY.
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT YOU'RE
IN DANGER OR THAT YOU NEED
MEDICAL HELP WHICH CAN ACTUALLY
TALK.
TO SOMEBODY LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE
DEPARTMENT SO I BELIEVE THERE'S
TECHNOLOGY DEPRESSED PROTECT
THESE WORKERS IN WAYS THAT I
THINK WE ALSO SHOULD TAKE THAT
EXTRA STEP. SO THAT THEY CAN
FEEL SAFE AND WHATEVER
ENVIRONMENT.
AND.
MIKE MY COLLEAGUE TO LEFT AND I.
HAVE.
SINCE WE GOT HERE HAVE BEEN
STAYING IN HOTELS.
SEVERAL AND HOTEL SANTA.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. IT.
AND ARE I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
TIMES WHERE.
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
I'VE COMMODITY SHOWER AT THE
SAME TIME SOME OF THE BEEN
KNOCKING.
AND THEY'VE COME TO THE DOOR.
BUT LUCKILY.
I'D IN EXPOSED LIFE OF.
SO MY CONCERN IS IF I.
HAD NOT HEARD SOMETHING A MY
SPIDER SENSE DIDN'T SAY
SOMEBODY'S.
IN HERE I NEED TO STOP AND LOOK
OUT.
THAT THAT COULD HAVE TURNED INTO
A SITUATION WHERE THEY'VE GONE.
TO YOUR MANAGEMENT.
IN SAID THAT I HAD BEEN
INAPPROPRIATE AND WITHOUT DUE
PROCESS.
ESPECIALLY THE ELECTED OFFICIAL.
THAT COULD BE NOT ONLY
EMBARRASSING BUT IT COULD BE
CAREER ENDING.
AND.
.
SO I I THINK WE ALSO NEED GO
FROM IN A JUDICIARY SIDE. TO
ENSURE.
THAT OBVIOUS WE DO NOT WANT TO
PROTECT.
PREDATORS.
BUT WE DON'T WANT TO GO AFTER
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE MADE AN HONEST MISTAKE?
AND ENDS AND THEN AND THAT WE
HAVE SOME TYPE OF.
DO PROCESS WHATEVER IT IS SO
THAT AUTUMN OF EVERYBODY'S
TREATED FAIRLY AND IN THAT CASE.
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY BEEN
CONCERNING TO ME AND IT IN A BIG
WAY OFFICE TO PERSONALLY BUT.
OF AN IN A BIG WAY AND SO I.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU
WILL WORK ON THIS I'VE HEARD
THIS OF LAST COUPLE OF DAYS. AND
JUDICIARY AND SO I WILL VOTE FOR
TODAY WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU WORK OUT THIS.
HOPEFULLY THE BENEFIT OF BOTH.
AND THEN WILL WILL LOOK AT
AGAIN WHEN A.
FERGUSON FLOOR.
VICE CHAIR FLOOR FOLLOWED BY
SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY.
THANK YOU HAVE FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT TOM.
STRANGE NOT TO PARTICULARLY LOVE
THIS BILL BECAUSE I THINK THE
PROTECTION OF WORKERS AND IS
FOREMOST AND WHAT ALL OF US WANT
TO DO ANTI AND FOR MY COMMENTS I
DO NOT WANT TO TO BE PERCEIVED.
IN THE SLIGHTEST BIT THAT THAT
WE CAN SOMEHOW DO NOT WANT TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND I DO
APPRECIATE DOWN OF. THE CHAIR OF
FOUND PUBLIC SAFETY SOME OF HIS
COMMENTS AS WELL BECAUSE WE'VE
EXPERIENCED SOME OF THAT TO NOW
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
SHOWER AND SOMEONE KNOCKS ON
DOOR NO DOUBT THEY'RE DOING
THEIR PROTOCOL KNOCKING A COUPLE
TIMES AND YOU START SCREAMING
AND YELLING THAT YOU'RE IN. HERE
AND YOU KNOW LIKE WE'VE ALL BEEN
THERE AND DONE THAT AND AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE DONE THAT MYSELF.
BUT LIKE MY CONCERN ON THE ON
THE PANIC BUTTONS.
TO YOUR POINT LIFE ASSIST IS A
COMPANY OUT THERE THAT THE HELP
FOR ELDERLY FOLKS THE FALL DOWN
THE HIT A BUTTON. AND THEN IT
TRIGGERS NINE ONE ONE AND THEN
THEY CAN TALK TO THEM IF YOU
KNOW WHAT THE ISSUES ARE. YOU
KNOW THAT IS OBVIOUSLY
SIGNIFICANT COST AND TO THE THE.
THE INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE IT'S A
SUBSCRIPTION BASED PROGRAM AND
SO IF THERE IS SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN WORK WITH YOU KNOW A COMPANY
LIKE THAT TO GIVE.
YOU KNOW REBATE OR SOMETHING
ALWAYS LIES TO PROTECT THESE
FOLKS BUT THAT'S A SUBSCRIPTION
BASED SERVICE AND THAT THAT IS
ACTUALLY OUT THERE IN COULD BE I
THINK EASILY MOVED INTO THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION.
MY CONCERN IS HONESTLY AND IT'S
BEEN SAID A COUPLE TIMES BUT IS
THE BLACKLIST.%
DOWN THE DUE PROCESS ASPECT IN
AND I KEEP TALKING TO THE CHAIR
PUBLIC SAFETY BECAUSE EVERYTHING
SITTING ON ON YOUR COMMITTEE
LAST EVERYTHING WE DO IN THIS
BILL IS ABOUT TO PROCESS.
EVERYTHING IN THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF THAT BEEN HERE HAS BEEN
DUE PROCESS AND ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
THERE IS NONE.
AND THAT'S A HUGE CONCERN OF
MINE.
BECAUSE.
WE DON'T WANNA PROTECT ABOUT
ACTORS WE ABSOLUTELY DO NOT AND
IF IF THEY'VE BEEN.
THREE NIGHTS THREE OUT OF THREE
NIGHTS AT THEIR STAND AND
THEY'VE HAD THIS ISSUE. I WAS
HOPE THE GENERAL MANAGER HAD ME
TO THAT OF WHAT CALL NINE ONE
ONE STATE IN THE LEFT AND THE
PATRON TELETYPE'S HIS SIDE OF
THE STORE AND LET THEM DEAL WITH
IT AT A LAW ENFORCEMENT DOWNSIDE
OF THIS THING.
I JUST HAVE A TREMENDOUS CONCERN
IT COULD EVEN ON THE ETHNIC SIDE
OF THIS THERE'S SOME OF OUR
CULTURES WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A LOT THE SAME NAMES.
AND SO AS WE GO THROUGH THIS AND
AND WHETHER IT'S JOHN SMITH OR
WHOEVER THAT MAY BE. THERE'S A
LOT OF THOSE OUT THERE.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF HE'S OUT
THERE ALBEIT BUT THERE'S A LOT
OF CULTURES THAT USE THE SAME
NAME SO THIS IS ONE OF MY
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL. IS WE
HAVE TO FIX THAT PROCESS.
AND I THINK QUITE FRANKLY THAT
THERE IS A SOLUTION BETWEEN.
THE FOLKS WE NEED TO BE
PROTECTED AND THE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE THIS IS I DON'T THINK
THE INDUSTRY IS SAYING THAT ALL
THAT WE DON'T PROTECT OUR POLICE
THEY'RE NOT SAYING THAT. WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING IS THERE ARE
SOME VERY BIG CONCERNS BECAUSE I
DO THINK THE INDUSTRY HAS A?
RIGHT TO PROTECT THE PATRONS AS
WELL.
BECAUSE FOR THIS DUE PROCESS
ASPECT OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL
SO I'M I'M SORRY I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY BUT I DO
NOT WANT IT TO BE THAT I DON'T
PROTECT WORKERS. BUT IF WE COULD
FIX THOSE TWO PARTS OF THIS BILL
AND I THINK THAT THE PANIC BUT
IS ACTUALLY EASILY. I'M NOT IS
ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT COULD
COULD EASILY BE DONE.
BUT THAT DUE PROCESS IS A
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
WITH THIS PARTICULAR LEGISLATION
SO THANK YOU JR.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR SOME
MINIMUM MCCARTY THANK YOU FIRST
YOU MADE A MOTION CORRECTED IN
HER SECOND.
THOUGHT A SECOND THAT I I DO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE.
FOR THE AUTHOR I SUPPORT THIS
BILL I'M A CO AUTHOR OF COURSE
UP. NOT A AND AMY WALKING BACK
BUT THEN. I DID I JUST I WOULD
ASK A QUESTION BUT BUT BEFORE I
GET THERE. I AS AS OUR VICE
CHAIR SAID WHAT WE'RE ALL ABOUT
PROTECTING.
EMPLOYEES RIGHTS TO TO GO TO
WORK AND TOO OFTEN WE COMPLAIN
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT TO
WORK THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT JUST.
WANT TO WORK AND IS NOT LOST
UPON US THAT THE PREDOMINATELY
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA PROBABLY
LATINAS ONLY PEOPLE THAT.
YOU KNOW MARGINALIZED LANGUAGE
AND OTHER ISSUES KNOWS FIRST
HAND BECAUSE MY WIFE AND MOTHER
IN LAW WORK AT THE MOTEL SIX OF
ORANGE FOR A LONG TIME MOVES ARE
WORKING SHE WAS FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD.
A CLEAN ROOMS WITH HER MOM FOR
FIVE YEARS AMONG WORK TO
FEATHER.
FIFTEEN YEARS AND DOWN. AND I
ASKED YOU IN THIS BILL CAME UP
WHEN THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WAS PROPOSING. AND I
SAID YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS
PROPOSAL OUT THERE SO YEAH I'VE
HEARD ABOUT.
THE.
THE NATIONAL DEBATE YOU AND I
SAID DID YOU EVER EXPERIENCE.
ANY OF THESE GOT THING SAYS
NOORT ATTACKS BUT.
DID PEOPLE ACT INAPPROPRIATELY
AND EXPOSE THEMSELVES AND YES.
AND IT WAS HUMILIATING THEY JUST
WANT TO GO TO WORK. DO THEIR JOB
AND GO HOME AND BE SAFE AND SO.
IT I THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT
WE DO MORE TO PROTECT WORKERS
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE. WHO ARE
MARGINALIZED FOR SO MANY REASONS
IN THE FIRST PLACE?
I THINK YOU FOR PUSHING THE
SPORT AND THAT FULLY EMBRACE
THIS AND I'M PROUD THAT OUR
COUNTY STEPPED. BACK TO LET ME
BE HAVE ONE. THAT QUESTION YOU
CAN BE HELPS WITH SO. THERE'S A
FEW CITIES HAVE DONE THIS.
TWO ONE SECONDS BRAND NEW SO WE
CAN'T FOCUS ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
THE ONE.
IN CHICAGO WAS WAS.
WAS LAST YEAR SO IT'S NEW AS
WELL BUT BUT THE ONE IN SEATTLE
BASEBALL ANALYSIS TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN IT AND IT DOES HAVE.
VIA THE LIST AND SO ANY UP
LESSONS THAT YOU COULD.
SHARE WITH US AS FAR AS OR FROM
THE PROPONENTS AS FAR AS HOW THE
IMPLEMENTATION WORKS AND HOW.
THAT'S WORKING THERE.
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT.
THAT HAVE BEEN PLACED ON THE
LIST AND IF THERE'S. DUE PROCESS
AND HOW THAT ALL WORKS.
YEAH.
THE AFTERNOON.
FIRST THE AUTHOR IN THE NAY YOU
GONNA HADN'T CONTEXT WOULD YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND THEN.
A BENEFIT WITH FISHER PHILLIPS
ON AFTER THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL
LOGINIS OF.
I CAN ANSWER QUESTIONS ON THE
STATUS OF THAT SEATTLE
LITIGATION.
ERIC PAUL START WRITTEN THANK
YOU.
AND AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW EVERYONE'S COMMENTS.
THIS IS.
.
SOMETHING THAT I.
I WAS CA SHARE YOUR.
APPRECIATION FOR DUE PROCESS
AND.
AS OF.
LAWYER AND.
AND AS SOMEONE WHO.
.
RECOGNIZES THAT THE BASIC
FAIRNESS OF.
OF.
MAKING SURE THAT ALLEGATIONS.
ARE PROPERLY ADDRESSED.
.
BUT THIS PROPOSAL WAS BASED ON
IN THE THE SEATTLE INITIATIVE.
WE WORKED WITH UNITE HERE TO.
.
DRAFT THIS BILL AND DOWN.
AND IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE BLACKLIST PORTION OF THE
SEATTLE.
INITIATIVE IS A CURRENTLY BEING
LITIGATED.
AN AND PERHAPS AT HOTEL.
ASSOCIATION REPRESENT CAN.
ADDRESS.
THE SPECIFICS OF THAT
LITIGATION. ARM.
AND I.
YOU NO AM FULLY COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING.
THE DUE PROCESS CONCERNS WHICH
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAVES
HAS ALREADY FLAGGED  AND AND
THAT WE'VE BEEN. DISCUSSING.
.
HOW TO RESOLVE?
THE CONCERNS AND.
WE EXPECT TO FULLY ADDRESS THEM.
AT THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NUMBER BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THEY THE.
THERE THERE IS SUCH AND A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM THE WORKERS SOME
OVER HEARING FROM THE HOTELS
MEAN. OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
THE THE HOUSEKEEPERS AND OTHER
HOTEL EMPLOYEES?
IS THAT THIS HAPPENS MORE
FREQUENTLY THAN THE.
THE HOTEL INDUSTRY.
.
ACKNOWLEDGES OR EVEN RECOGNIZES.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF BEING
FIRED OR BRING DISCIPLINE THEY
DON'T REPORT IT. AND SO.
IN AND WE'VE WE'VE AYE I'VE
HEARD SEVERAL TIMES THAT IT
OFTENTIMES IT'S REPEAT ACTORS
THEY HAVE FREQUENT.
GAS AT HOTELS THAT.
.
AND THE.
THE THAT THE WORKERS MADE MAY
COME TO. RECOGNIZE AS THE.
THAT THE BAD ACTORS.
.
AND SO THAT IS THE POINT OF THIS
BLACKLIST WE WE HAVE HEARD.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THAT THERE
ARE BAD ACTORS REPEAT BAD ACTORS
THAT.
THAT CAN AND AND NEED TO BE
DEALT WITH.
.
WHETHER THIS BLACK LIST.
PROPOSAL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
IS IS THAT THE PROPER APPROACH
OR NOT BUT YOU KNOW WE WE ARE.
GOING TO ADDRESS THOSE DUE
PROCESS CONCERNS OF THE FOR THE
LITIGATION IN SEATTLE WAS IT
IMPLEMENTED. THE THE BLACKLIST
IN SEATTLE AND AND HOW DID THEY
GO ABOUT ADDRESSING THAT DID
LISTING.
PROCESS I DON'T KNOW I I WOULD
HAVE TO DO.
DEFER TO.
BUT CERTAIN SO THERE WAS A LOT
OF LITIGATION FILED BY THE
INDUSTRY.
WITH RESPECT TO THE SEATTLE
ORDINANCE.
MULTIPLE PROVISIONS IN THE
ORDINANCE WITHRESPECT TO THE
BLACKLIST THE TRIAL COURT. RULED
THAT THE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS
ABOUT HAVE STANDING TO CHALLENGE
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY. OF HAVE
THEIR GAS THEY SAID IT WAS MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR A GUEST TO HAVE
BEEN PLACED ON THE BLACKLIST.
NOT TO CHALLENGE NOT NAM SO THEY
CAN GET TO THE UNDERLYING MERITS
OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL. ISSUES.
THAT IS IT DECISION ITSELF IS
CURRENTLY UNDER APPEAL THERE
HADN'T BEEN OR ARE YOU MAY YET
SO THAT'S THE STATUS OF. THE
CHALLENGE TO THE SEATTLE
INITIATIVE.
MAKE.
I THINK YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE HAD.
A ROBUST DISCUSSION ON THIS
ISSUE.
BOTH THE.
THE MANY PROS FOR THE BILL. AND
A FEW OF THE CONCERNS THAT
MEMBERS HAVE EXPRESSED.
I I GUESS THE ONLY OTHER THING
THAT I WOULD ADD. NOT WANTING TO
REPEAT.
I ASSURE ME THE SAME SENTIMENTS
ABOUT.
PROTECT WORKERS.
.
I WOULD ONLY ASK THIS QUESTION
IT SEEMS TO ME.
THERE IS AN INHERENT POWER
BALANCE.
AGAINST WORKER.
IN THAT WE STILL LIVE IN AN ERA
WHERE WE ALWAYS SAY.
THE CUSTOMERS RIGHT.
EVEN NOW.
AND THAT IT IS VERY RISKY AND
DANGEROUS.
FOR.
A HOTEL WORKER.
TO MAKE A COMPLAINT
AGAINST A GUEST.
THAT COULD EASILY BE BALLOTS
BACK
AS
DISCIPLINE.
AGAINST THE WORKER.
AND I GUESS I WOULD PASS THOSE
WHO'VE OPPOSE THIS BILL TODAY.
DOESN'T JUST THAT INHERENT IN
BALANCE.
MAKE YOU SEE. OR SAY LET US TAKE
EVERY EFFORT WE CAN.
TO ENSURE BOUNCE.
AND PROTECT WORKERS.
IF ANYONE
AND THE OPPOSITION PANEL WISHES
TO ADDRESS THAT WILL WELCOME
THAT IF NOT WE'VE GOT A MOTION
THAT'S BEEN SECOND AND THIRD IT
WE CAN JUST MOVE ON.
COURSE WE WANT ABOUT.
AS WE PROTECT OUR WORKERS.
YOU CAN'T.
HERE AT ALL.
MATTER OF.
HOW WE DO IT?
FOR.
MORE OF KIND.
BECOMING TO JUST IF I COULD
JUST.
I THINK IN TERMS OF.
BUT NEW YORK AND I AM MATH THAT
THE.
NEVER BROUGHT UP.
IT'S IN A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT.
OTHER HOTELS IN NEW YORK NEW
YORK NEW JERSEY AREA
I'M IN THAT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THAT PANIC
BUTTONS FOR THREE YEARS.
ONE HOTEL BRAND IS IMPLEMENTED
IT NATIONWIDE.
I'M IN ALL THERE SO.
AND A LOT OF OTHER ONES ARE
LOOKING AT IT AS WELL SET WE
OBVIOUSLY RECOGNIZES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE TESTIMONY
TODAY. A WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
WITNESSES ARE AUTHOR AND.
THOSE WHO CAME FORWARD BRAVELY
TO SHARE THEIR STORIES THAT
CANNOT BE EASY TO DO.
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT THIS
BILL HAS A A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
A MOTION SECOND AND THIRD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY THURMAN AYE THURMOND
AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CONSULTS LECTURE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
COLORI MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH.
BUT THE BILL'S OUT A
CONGRATULATIONS THAT IS OUR ONE
AND ONLY BILL TODAY THIS
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING. THANK YOU
CAN THIS MEANS JACK